e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have a
public hearing this morning on an
amendment uh on House Bill
6119 uh before we get to that though I'd
ask you to please join me in the Pledge
of
Allegiance I pledge of
to the flag of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
everyone again we are here today uh to
consider an amendment or here testimony
on an amendment uh from all of you uh on
House Bill 619 it is amendment number
2023 hyen 2359
H um it is our custom in this committee
and has been our practice for this past
year to allow the prime sponsor extra
time because they're giving the
background and the Genesis of the bill
representative Lon I'd ask her to come
forward at this time she is the prime
sponsor uh she has agreed to abide by
the same three minute rule that all
individuals will be asked to abide by
and we do have a three-minute uh rule on
testimony mainly because we want to
ensure that everybody has a equal chance
to to participate and offer their input
representative I'm sorry representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman I have a
point of order which is that having
looked very carefully at the side by
side um there are modifications to the
original bill but there is no added
content that is different from the
subject matter of of the original Bill
and therefore I fail to understand how
this is a non- gerine Amendment it is my
understanding that the speaker has
however ruled that it is a non-gain
Amendment so we are where we are because
he is the speaker and I am not uh but I
just want it to be clear that I think
that this hearing is simply a second
rehearing of a hearing we've already had
and I I thank you very much for your
Indulgence and letting me say so
certainly thank you for that uh that
comment representative Weber uh this
both the speaker and the clerk have have
been consulted on this matter and they
both are in agreement that this hearing
was was necessary so accordingly we we
are here uh representative Le if I may
make one correction the clerk assures me
that the speaker ruled that it was a
non-gain Amendment okay okay thank you
Leon good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee and members of the public
for the record my name is Erica Leon and
I represent the town of Derry I want to
start off by speaking to the transgender
community and those who love them this
amendment and the bill that it replaces
do not seek to erase you we do not seek
to invalidate your experience this
effort is to prioritize your lifelong
health and well-being by Pro pumping the
brakes on the rapid adoption of this
medical care for your age group we know
that you were focused on your personal
struggles and on finding an immediate
solution I get that but as somebody who
worked with medical Innovation for
almost two decades I know that it's also
important to make sure that there are
data in people like you and by like you
I mean your age and your prior medical
history before getting too excited that
some surgery will in fact change your
life for the better without unexpected
side effects for over a
decade representative excuse me I'm
sorry I have one more point of order
which is I don't believe that signs are
allowed in the committee rooms are they
not I'm sorry you're going to have to
leave it uh put that down it's down
okay yeah thank you sorry thank you
resume representative Leon for over a
decade I worked to find money to drive
Research into new medical Technologies
and expand them to New Markets I saw the
successes and I also saw the body count
of the failures I saw how one failed
medical intervention can Cascade into a
lifetime of poor health and reduce
quality of life and my experience was
usually with people much older than
teenagers usually on the opposite end of
the age Spectrum the amendment we're
discussing today replaces the entire
original bill that means the school
section is out entirely as is discussion
of puberty blockers cross- sex hormones
and surgeries such as masectomy today
we're talk here to talk about two things
first is should the state of New
Hampshire allow bottom surgeries in
people under 18 some ask if these
surgeries are done in New Hampshire
hopefully there's people behind me that
can give us solid conclusive data
however we do know that Boston
Children's Hospital vaginoplasties are
done in those who are 17 and
older in a world path uh World path
study um a survey in
2017 of 20 centers in the US that
provide this care half of them provided
genital surgeries to minors so this is
something that is happening the question
is is this something that we should be
doing in this this state or should we
allow the science to proceed without us
with those who really need to see it
going to other states and the people of
the state waiting for more data so that
outcomes right now it's only
vaginoplasties that can happen in those
that are 17 phop plasties have such high
risk of um of a need for reintervention
early on it's almost 60% that those
aren't allowed by guidelines and those
who are under
18 if you look to the handout that I
gave you this one here from the Mosaic
Clinic in San Francisco go it speaks to
the type of vaginoplasty that is done in
miners it's the part where I I
underlined who can get a PPT
vaginoplasty this surgery can be a great
option for patients whose other options
are limited to including colon
vaginoplasty this includes patients
needing revision surgery a few others
and patients who have been on puberty
blockers patients also can choose to
have this type of vagary plasty as their
primary surgery if they understand and
accept the that there are no long-term
data on the outcomes of this
surgery we asked the question do we
legislate the practice of
medicine in 2018 this legislature said
yes when they banned conversion therapy
for minors there are no long-term data
on vagin PPT vaginoplasties and that is
the only realistic solution offered in
this age group and representative L on
your time is up thank you any questions
representative Weber did you have a
question I was just going to say that we
do have a longstanding permission for
the uh author of a u particular
amendment to be able to present it so I
have no objection to that happening yeah
I mean representative Lon did wave that
uh she did want to abide by the feem
minute well I did give you a few little
extra time because of the interruption
earlier um but uh you know again
represent just sure
sure absolutely yeah representative
Missour thank you for taking my question
can you tell me a little bit more about
the second part of this bill oh yes
thank you um thank you representative
Missour and thank you Mr chairman and uh
and representative Weber um this the
second part of this bill is when this
body decided to legislate the practice
of medicine back in
2018 in 2017 the bill a bill was
introduced to Pro prohibit what really
is a barbaric practice and it fell out
of favor decades in the
past in the past horrible things were
done by people to try and make their
sexuality conform and that's simply not
okay at the time there was the concern
about how do we also make sure that this
bill that this what now law this this
prohibition on certain medical practices
in our law doesn't impact the
transgender Community the way that that
was done is there was a line was added
that said that
um I'm sorry there was the one that said
that um that if you're undergoing gender
transition it's not conversion therapy
the problem is we heard two years ago
that this is limiting the practice of
medicine there are some providers who
are afraid to come to New Hampshire and
treat minors because they don't know
what would be considered to be um
practices or treatments that seek to
change their gender or G gender identity
in the world path guidelines they
actually Define conversion therapy as
attempts to
compel um attempts to compel a change in
gender or a change in gender ideology um
I believe that the words attempt to
compel are far easier to understand and
one that a provider would be less afraid
of inadvertently uh of having a memory
from a patient um than bring them to the
licensing
board we also have the issue that the
language that somebody pursuing a gender
transition is not inclusive to those who
take a more Meandering path or those
whose ultimate Destiny is a non
non-binary identity right now the way
that the language is written um if the
licensing board were to take this on its
face value Physicians who are following
guidelines which say that healthc Care
Professionals working with gender
diverse adolescence should facilitate
exploration and expression of gender
openly and respected so that no
particular gender identity is favored
that this could cause a problem that's
why I have brought some other language
to better clarify this language I want
to make sure that everybody is treated
with respect and that we aren't
experimenting on our
17-year-olds according to that clinic in
San
Francisco there are no long-term data we
should pump the brakes and we should
also clarify that language because if we
have three more providers that are
providing mental health care in New
Hampshire that means we're looking at
maybe 600 more appointments for our
youth we're in a crisis among all youth
transgender Youth and other youth we
need to make sure that those services
are available and I believe that by
taking the hard CH hard hard task of
actually trying to change this language
we'll be able to save
lives thank you thank you other
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Leon for taking my
question I noticed in the bill if you go
back and look at on page
33-35 there's a reference to the
insurance not being able to provide
coverage for this can you help me
understand that in the world of Arissa
which is a federal law that most
insurance companies today are
self-funded and therefore therefore come
under Arisa we cannot as a state
supersede what the federal law says
within Arissa so in essence even though
we're talking talking about trying to
minimize the insurance coverage in
essence we're talking about a very small
percentage of the population at best 15%
maybe 18% that would be impacted so can
you speak to that issue between the
state law which what you're talking
about and orisa which is a
um thank you representative Merchant for
that question when I brought this
amendment it was out of our work as a
subcommittee to try and find those areas
that we may be able to agree upon which
is on the genital surgery on minors and
perhaps finding more respectful language
on conversion therapy the way that I did
that was to take the existing section
that dealt with the medical care and
simply change it so that it wasn't for
all gender conversion therapy but to
limit it to the genital gender
reassignment surgeries um
we can talk about those details about
that specific language but now that we
actually have a proposal that U May that
that may actually solve the needs of our
state I think that that's something for
us to work through if we did not have
that section in there would you be would
you would you be more supportive if we
remove that section followup
representative thank you um thank you
for addressing the question it does to
your point it does not really get to the
detail between federal law versus state
law which we cannot obviously
exceed this federal law change the
federal law through a state law but back
to the other question I have is this
deals with a parent as well and we
talked about this
earlier why are we talking about parents
and parental rights on one side of the
equation but now we're talking about not
giving the parents on the other side the
same rights here because this is really
coming down to having the parent and if
I understand all arguing about parental
rights it's parents rights suede yet
here those rights don't so explain to me
why a parent on one side of the equation
has all these rights but now we're
taking them away um thank you for the
question to the first to the first point
of this follow-up question there are
over half of the states that even in
their Medicare programs and their
Medicaid pro programs they do not pay
for these surgeries so while there is a
f federal law not all states are
following that um but we can discuss
that portion um when we meet together as
a subcommittee or a full Committee in
exec um to your second point
parental rights um are limited at some
points a parent can't authorize their
child to go use heroin and then mean
that that is within rights we know that
heroin is dangerous and nobody would do
that but a parent also can't authorize
their child to go suntanning in the
state of New Hampshire because those
under 18 cannot go to a tanning salon
those under 18 can't get a driver's
license without their parents paying for
um the state sponsored or the state
endorsed driver's
training we need to look at the entire
landscape and it's not an issue of
either we're entirely permissive and
absolutely anything goes in a state of
Anarchy or one in which the state is
your actual parent we need to look at
that nuance and understand that most
people don't realize that when you're 17
and if you've been on puberty blockers
your only option is a paranal
vaginoplasty one which the Mosaic um
Clinic in San Francisco
appropriately says has no long-term data
on outcomes this is one of those areas
where parents are looking to do the
absolute best that they can for their
kids but they're not going to understand
that detail and Nuance to know that the
PPT ones are very different than the
ones that have been done for decades the
risks are much higher and the durability
the the need for revision is different
look I come from the world of orth of
Orthopedics and all sorts of medical
devices with knes as you get two shots
on goal you wait as long as possible for
your first knee replacement because when
that fails you'll get a revision surgery
that takes even more bone after that
revision surgery you will be in a
wheelchair and that's just your knee on
the vaginoplasties you can have a
primary surgery and then a revision
surgery and then you're going into
groundbreaking
territory by pumping the brakes and
saying wait a little longer see about
some data and don't think that you're
getting the same surgery that your older
neighbor had we can make sure that
nobody is getting that knee at 25 or 17
and then suddenly when they have an
infection they have something else in
need of revision and then that has a
problem later they're left without
options I want to
prioritize the health of 80-year-old
transgenders just as much as 18 and I
want those 18-year-olds to grow up and
be healthy and live a long good
productive happy life with as few
medical complications as possible I
think that drawing a line and stopping
these PPT uh vaginoplasties will protect
more and will increase Everybody's
Health
overall thank you any other questions
members seeing none thank you very much
you
also signed up to testify this morning
pred is it Reed or
pred it's Reed thank you sorry I just uh
no that's okay getting testimony for you
handwriting thank you thank you so much
you have about three minutes thank you
um chair and uh representative Leon uh
for considering my testimony I wanted to
speak to a few key
considerations uh or um opposing this
amendment uh as representing the ACLU of
New Hampshire
um and largely speaking to that uh like
the original Bill uh unfortunately the
amendment remains as h hostile
legislation that unfairly targets and
discriminates against transgender and
gender non-conforming people in the
granite state and that even though um as
you'll hear and as uh allies in the
lgbtq advocacy Community have heard from
providers that gender affirming
surgeries and minors are exceptionally
rare a total ban that overrides private
medical decisions between doctors and
their families is unnecessary and
harmful and it's Reckless for
legislators to deny vulnerable people
care that their doctors May believe is
medically
necessary and a threat to
anyone um element of gender affirming
care leaves room for future attacks on
age appropriate care for transgender
Youth and gender affirming care is
widely recognized as being the only
evidence-based approach to addressing
the healthcare needs of transgender
adolescents including severe mental
health
risks and according to the medical uh
American Medical
Association uh evidence that restricting
access to gender firming care can
produce tragic effects on transgender
persons disproportionately at risk of
anxiety stress substance use disorder
and
suicide and I want to stress that the
amendment singles out restrictions to
health care for transgender Youth and
the prohibition of genital gender
reassignment
surgery uh and that it this restriction
only applies to transgender youth
however not to minors with disorders of
sex
development despite that these
procedures as I stated are exceedingly
uncommon for youth to undergo this
language sends a message to health that
the healthcare needs of trans people are
less valid than those of intersex
individuals or individuals with sex
developmental disorders and there have
been various appell Court decisions that
have ruled against attempts to limit
gender affirming care in the eighth
circuit and brand B rutage in Arkansas a
gender affirming care band was
overturned on grounds that it violated
the 14th Amendment um on the basis of
discrimination um as well as in Williams
be Kincade in the fourth circuit and
they also declared that uh gender
affirming care
um is extended um and that it's
protected under the Americans with
Disabilities Act for people experiencing
gender
dysphoria and I also want to note that
the language in the amendment
surrounding insurance coverage for
minors and for adults is in violation of
New Hampshire's anti-discrimination laws
uh as they've been applied to insurance
and you can see RSA
4174 8B and
RSA uh 420
G6 you wrap up please yeah thank you um
I'd be happy to send the rest of my
comments to the committee later thank
you so much very much question from
committee members represent look like
you were about to ask a question
questions representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for being here um is gender
dysphoria a medical
disorder is that your
understanding uh from my understanding
gender dysphoria has medically
appropriate treatment that should be
provided without interference from the
state and according to the best judg of
Physicians and their families thank you
questions I'm seeing none uh okay you
keep moving your microphone
representative sh do you have a question
I do not have a question for the person
testifying I have a question for the
chair okay all right great thank you for
your testimony thank you representative
representative uh sharo you could see
that I wanted to talk um I I was just
wondering if we could arrange the
people testifying so that we hear um
people from Dartmouth Hitchcock if they
are here to provide testimony earlier
because I think hearing from the people
who actually provide medical services is
foundational for all the other um issues
that we're going to discuss I have no
um
sorry as I've said before it's more of
an art and a science in terms of
arranging the cards but uh no you make a
valid point representative Shapiro um
okay uh I'd like to call Courtney Tanner
from drouth Health next um to
speak
good morning good morning are you have
three minutes sure for the record
Courtney Tanner I serve as a senior
director for government relations for
Dartmouth Health uh Dartmouth Health
provides comprehensive quality care to
patients across the state as the state's
only academic Medical Center we are
proud to provide Specialty Care to our
patients that need complex care
Dartmouth Health has provided high
quality gender affirming care to both
both pediatric and adult patients our
multi-disciplinary clinic and program
both in Lebanon and the southern clinics
um is the only program in the state that
that supports pediatric and adult
patients through transgender um gender
transitions we have multidisiplinary
teams of doctors nurses social workers
and more all of whom are highly skilled
and trained all of whom care deeply
about their patients and their parents
um Dartmouth Health has concerns about
the amendment as introduced today um to
represented Weber's point we uh have
some concerns that this is um very
similar to the bill that we testified in
opposition to last legislative session
um but there are some differences to
representative lon's uh point the first
section of this bill or I should say the
second after the definition section
prohibits a a physician from Prov
performing gender uh reassignment surger
surgery on a patient 17 years or older
it also prohibits any physician or
Provider from referring a patient um to
to um gender reassignment surgeries for
example in Boston or another state
providers um broadly uh we at Dartmouth
Health have a general uh rule that um
gen that surgery gender affirming
surgery is not per performed on minors
however if you turn to um the list of
exceptions in the bill I think the list
of exceptions in of themselves point to
the fact that sometimes there are
medical necessity there are reasons to
have um medical necessity reasons that
there would be surgery um I would also
note that broadly speaking we there's a
um a principle here that we we don't
like to legislate medicine these are
complex subject matters that are really
between a patient and a provider I'm
listening to the questions that are
asked here today and gosh I certainly
couldn't answer them I'm not a provider
and these these conversations really
should be had between a provider and a
patient in the in the physician's room I
also would like to note that section
three prohibits the use of public funds
for transgender assignment resurgery
including Medicaid reimbursement we
really believe believe that this
prohibition would drive um further Drive
Healthcare inequities um as stated these
uh when there are when there is a need
to access this type of care they are
rare um but they're medically necessary
and so um any barriers to to necessary
treatment um that is health and Equity
I'm happy to take questions um you'll
see coming around there's a uh we are
submitting written testimony on behalf
of the health system uh there's a list
of providers that illustrate um largely
um doctors phys Physicians but nurses
social workers um psychologists that are
in opposition of this um of this
legislation thank you representative
chapero yes thank you Mr chair
um I wonder if you could speak um
generally um and specifically to people
who who might be pursuing um some kind
of surgery um what does what part do
parents or Guardians play
in the involvement with the care of
someone 18 and younger um and what part
do they play in actually consenting to
any treatment for someone under 18 sure
so no matter what the type of care is uh
we always encourage I'm I'm listening to
our um our chair of Department of
Pediatrics uh in replaying in my head
right now um and he always says that we
encourage if not Champion parental
involvement in treatment um plan
development no matter the type of care
whether this is GI care or gender
affirming care
um uh and further it's the it's the law
that um parents need to consent to
treatment so anyone under 18 parents or
Guardians need to consent to
treatment thank you other representative
Nel thank you Mr chair Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question um I want
to make sure I heard you correctly it
said I think you said at some point
during your testimony that you have a
principle at Dartmouth that you don't do
these kinds of surgeries and people in
this age group is did I hear that right
that's our general policy yes and is how
was that policy
created uh that's a great question I'll
have to get back to you on that um but
that is a general policy that we have um
as created clinically um but I would
have to get back to on the details of
that it's a great question and is it in
writing or is it just a either thing
well I mean there are clinical criteria
that have to be met for any type of
surgery regardless of age and so um
those are clinical decisions that have
that are made within our department um I
have to I'll have to get back to you on
whether or not this is in writing or not
I don't have a copy of it in front of me
if there was the decision that this type
of surgery needed to be done in somebody
the age group would that patient be
referred out of um the
institution it depends if we can provide
that care or not um so sometimes we we
can provide that care for persons under
um eight for persons under 18 17 or
younger however it is a very rare
exception and I actually think the bill
itself highlights a few areas in which
that um exception may be may be valid
and may be medically
necessary representative kushman and
Merchant thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for being here miss Tanner um can
you tell me what your medical specialty
is I do not have a medical specialty I'm
an attorney by training and I have a
masters in social work thank you may
have a follow follow up um okay so if we
should be hearing from providers from
Dartmouth Hitchcock for these technical
questions um is why was no one sent from
Dartmouth so our providers are in our
providers are in clinic today and
they're unable to be here that's why
they have me okay and one FR one one one
more yeah would you it's my
understanding that um all medical
facilities per New Hampshire statute
have to have um written and printed um
policies and procedures for their
practice um so I'm assuming that
Dartmouth has written guidelines on when
this would be okay for um anyone under
18 and when it would not and what the
guidelines are would you be able to get
us those policies and proed as I stated
to representative Nel I'm happy to
Circle back on that certainly thank you
thank you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you m gney taking the T Tanner for
taking the question courney is fine in
regards to following up on represent
Nel's um the policy it says here on your
letter as well that the organization
does not include gender firming
surgeries for transgender miners does it
also exclude in the policy for a
provider to make a referral that's
question one if you will and then number
two does Dartmouth Hitchcock know of any
other policy you have that prohibits a
provider from making any other kind of
referral so two questions do you have a
policy specifically prohibiting a
provider from making that referral and
do you have any other policies with any
other prohibitions on referrals so I'm
going to take those questions down as I
Circle back with um other policies
forthcoming um but I'll say that
referrals are made only when medically
necessary so um yeah I would just leave
it at
that representative ma thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so correct me if I'm wrong but you said
what are those um you mentioned medical
NE Necessities is that medical
Necessities that warrant surgery or what
were medical Necessities that warrant
what well every patient is different
right and every um every clinical case
needs something different and so it's
really hard for me to answer a general
question like that when every patient's
going to need something different from
their provider and again I think that
that really points to that these
conversations have to be happening
between a patient and a
provider did you have a follow-up
representative yeah so
just to clarify though are you saying
that if there medical Necessities would
warrant surgery at Dartmouth
Hitchcock like what and what if so what
kind of medical Necessities is are
those so again I think that those
conversations have to be happening
between a provider and and their patient
and is it a yes is yes or no is I well I
guess I'm not understanding the question
to be a yes or no question yes so
is surgery done at Dartmouth Hitchcock
in the case of a medical necessity it's
our general rule that surgery is not
performed on minors um for gender
affirming care however there are rare
exceptions when they're medically
necessary what are those
exceptions that has to be that has to be
decided on between a patient and a
provider would it be fair to say Case by
case absolutely absolutely as requested
before can you send us a list of those
exceptions will work on providing the
the written policy thank you
representative representative
Palmer so in that
vein one of the things that I'd also be
concerned about
is I don't know how you can make a list
of every possible exception that needs
to be made um and so because even if you
get all of the best surgeons best
doctors best providers of this kind of
care there's going to be the next case
that shows up that doesn't fit that
criteria absolutely and so I guess my
question is would the physicians at
Dartmouth be nervous about having just a
specific list of exceptions and if it if
it's not on the
list what happens yes absolutely and and
also that c care is innovative right so
um I think again as I stated earlier the
the list of exceptions in this bill
alone illustrates that there are times
where it's clinically roate um however
we know we move slow in our in this
realm of the world and so it's really
dangerous to legislate medicine this
way other questions from committee
much also signed up to speak is James
bubach I believe it is from the New
Hampshire Psychological
Association
good
morning how did I do that pronunciation
was I
close okay I'm
sorry can you turn your microphone
on good morning to the committee chair
and members of the committee and again
you have three minutes sir my name is Dr
Jim bomersbach I am a licensed
psychologist in New Hampshire and work
as a forensic psychologist here uh I
moved to New Hampshire and so I am one
of those people who has started to build
my life and and find a place here in New
Hampshire and I represent the New
Hampshire Psychological Association uh
which is a professional organization of
over 200 psychologists active in
practice in New Hampshire right now uh
and I am here today to speak on behalf
of that organization in opposition to
this amendment and this
legislation uh specifically uh the New
Hampshire psychological psychological
associ Association was an organization
that was
uh eager to contribute to the ban on
conversion therapy in 2018 and to make
sure that those practices would not be
allowed in this state uh it is unclear
to me why uh the uh sponsors of this
bill have uh alluded to some sort of
conflation between gender affirming care
which is a uh category of services
provided by medical uh provid ERS who
are licensed in the state and uh subject
to the board uh of medicine uh and con
and uh conversion therapy which is
a a uh unfounded
unscientific practice that seeks to uh
impose the wills of parents and and
adults on minors uh there is
no uh similarity between these two
practices and so to conf plate them in
this bill as the as there appears to be
an attempt to uh just does not make
sense to me or the members of my
organization who I
represent
uh I'm a psychologist I'm not a medical
provider I can speak to uh mental health
issues that appear uh as a result of uh
gender dysphoria and that gender
affirming care is a good solution for
those individuals who are uh struggling
with gender sephoria that this is a uh
this is an emerging area of care I agree
with the sponsors of the build that is
the case um however that would then in
my mind beg the question of why at this
early stage are we choosing to ban this
procedure which is not the same thing as
conversion therapy there is no
legitimate purpose for conversion
therapy there is no scientific evidence
that it could work um that is not the
case with gender affirming care or any
of the things that may be falling under
that umbrella
uh so I'm here basically to ask to
answer questions uh on the mental health
front if you guys have questions I'm
happy to try to address them okay thank
you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr
chair so when we um heard
testimony a year or two ago about um
another bill which was going to um
repeal the ban on conversion therapy
we heard um some forceful testimony from
a very limited number of um clinicians
who said that the statute as it now is
and I don't know if you're familiar with
the actual wording of the statute as it
currently reads that the that the
wording would um
discourage
clinicians um from talking to adolescen
about sexuality about their questions
about sexuality about their discomfort
um so that it would um discourage
General discussion with um youth which I
think we would all agree is really
important so from your practice or from
your ideas representing this American
Psychological Association New Hampshire
Psychological Association would you
think the current statute would
discourage people from talking to
adolescence
about um sexual concerns uh in my
opinion no uh my organization is not
aware of any individuals who have come
to us and said that they have had board
complaints or have had clients come to
them with concerns about uh discussions
General about uh sexual uh orientation
or gender identity um in my uh
understanding there there haven't been
any board complaints in the four years
uh based on on on this uh change to to
the legislation uh and there's always
going to be a small minority of uh
providers who
will be willing to allow their
professional uh demeanor to be
influenced by political attitudes uh
part of the nice thing about working for
an organization that represents hundreds
of psychologists is that we get a wide
variety of of perspectives and and opin
and histories and again our organization
as a whole we have people who come
forward and say that we are supporting
this ban as it is currently written we
came forth in 2020 to maintain our
support for that bill and we continue
our support for that consistent ban on
questions representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um so is it NE
necessary for us to um legislate the
practice of around psychology wouldn't
this um wouldn't conversion therapy
already be um you know against the
principles and the ethics guidelines and
the administrative rules for
psychologists in New Hampshire without
the language that's currently in
question part of the difficulty with
conversion therapy and the necessity for
a ban for it was that it was often not
something that was advertised or
publicly uh offered uh but something
that was done uh
through Less open
means uh so you had providers who had
unclear
certifications who had um uh facilities
that may or may not be uh within good
standing in terms of their ability to
provide care for people uh and so there
was less clarity about who was going to
be providing this this practice and
whether or not they would be accountable
to a board uh so in this case a ban was
a reasonable effort to try to make sure
that no one can can provide these
Services whether or not they are
licensed and uh that contrasts with
gender affirming care which is uniformly
practiced in by people who have medical
licenses uh and so again I don't see the
comparison between the two
follow
up okay thank you and um I'm just
that I apologize
can't any other questions uh
representative mour thank you thank you
for taking my question um so do you
think guidance counselors and schools
are able to appropriately counsel
children who are experiencing gender
dysphoria uh
I would say yes or no it would depend on
the case uh there are certainly going to
be individuals who uh would need a low
level of care me the vast majority of
folks who experience some questions
about their gender identity um are going
to be sort of just questioning having a
low level of Interest or or curiosity um
for those folks who need uh more
intensive care they're likely going to
need a higher level of services and it
would depend on the qualifications of
the guidance counselor in that school to
recognize whether or not they have the
qualifications and training appropriate
to offer those services or to refer that
to a more trained and specialized
provider yeah you have a followup yep
um yes so do you receive a lot of
referrals from guidance counselors and
schools for that then uh my organization
represents uh
psychologists
um and I am not acting as a clinical
psychologist in my own practice as I
said at the beginning I am a forensic
psychologist working with the criminal
justice system uh I can tell you that my
colleagues uh who I've spoken with have
not had a have not reported a large
counselors but I can follow up with uh
with my colleagues and see if if there
have been uh more referrals that they
haven't discussed with me
personally representative Weber and then
thank you I think I've thought better of
my question I think it's been answered
thank you very much thank you
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman um so going back to thank you
it's hard to do both at once I'm doing
I'm playing Clerk and trying to for
which I'm very grateful by the way um so
thanks for your patience um I'm
wondering going back to you were
discussing that there would be those um
Fly by Night operations that are um
engaging in conversion therapy um
are those are those kinds of operations
violating Licensing Laws at that point
if they're practicing psychology but
they're not
licensed again it would depend on the
circumstances of that individual
operation um there have been uh there
have been situations I believe I'm aware
of where uh they have employed people
who have had some sort of medical
license or who have had uh affiliated
health license um but again
I'm speaking based on my own you know
reading of of newspaper stories and and
at this point so I can't speak to any
specific uh one of these operations I've
only been aware from testimonials people
who have been who have lived experiences
when they've talked about their
experiences there uh talking about the
uh operators of these facilities not
necessarily having the appropriate
lure representative Missour thank you
again so is the association you
represent in support of gender
reassignment surgery for minors when it
is medically indicated and there has
been discussion between the minor uh if
they have a parent or Guardian present
to have the GU par guarding party the
conversation uh to have medical
providers as part of the conversation
then yes generally we are supportive of
individuals who are seeking medical care
that they are able to access that
medical
carek you other questions from committee
members I'm seeing none uh seeing none
much also signed up to speak is Sam
Hampshire again sir you have about three
minutes
yes good morning morning thank you for
the opportunity to testify today my name
is Sam Hawkins I'm the the public policy
assistant at Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness Nami
New Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire I'm here today to
speak in opposition to both Amendment
2359 and HB 619 itself I'll keep my
comments simple as we've heard from a
lot of professionals and I think we have
more in the bank and again sir the focus
of this hearing is on the amendment at
yes of
course Nomine Hampshire believes that
all people should be treated with
respect and dignity and should have
access to mental and physical healthare
free from interference as a result of
stigma and discrimination lgbtq plus
individuals especially those who are
transgender or gender non-conforming are
often at an elevated risk for
experiencing anxiety and depression
however Nami New Hampshire recognizes
that with access to affirming health
care and support within their homes and
communities this risk can be avoided
simply put gender affirming care works
it's saves lives and enhances the
well-being of those who need it
therefore we oppose any harmful policies
targeting lgbtq plus individuals such as
the limit on gender firm care in section
one of this amendment we also remain
firm in our opposition of the harmful
practice of conversion therapy and
oppose any policies that may enable its
use in our opinion section two of this
amendment would soften the statutory
definition of conversion therapy
increasing the risk of this practice
being used against lgbtq plus
individuals when they seek affirming
mental health care for those reasons I
ask you to please oppose Amendment 2023
2359 thank you thank you questions from
committee
members representative
kushman thank you for recognizing me and
thank you for taking my
question um I understand that uh there
is a common un common understanding that
um transgender youth are at higher risk
of suicide
ideation and um that the frunt of that
um research comes from the Trevor
Project is that your understanding also
thank you for your question we have
received a lot of or read a lot of
research from the Trevor Project uh I'm
not sure that I would indicate that
they're the primary source but I'm not
the expert on all of that uh research
okay thank
you other
you also signed up to speak is
representative Alicia leas from Hudson
38 thank you morning representative um
again you have three minutes
welcome um I just I appreciate what
you're doing here I think it's a really
really good job I want to say that to
begin with I just wanted to talk about a
couple make a couple points one is
um I like your definition the fact that
you defined gender and sex because while
we can change our gender we can't change
our sex because it's written into every
single one of the cells in our
system
and one thing I wanted to point out
you're talking about surgery but I did
want to point out that hormones which
are often done in conjunction with all
of this if you have hormones of the
opposite sex they are um toxic to your
system and while we as legislators
shouldn't be mandating what people can
and can adults can and can't do um it is
our respon it is I think our duty to to
at least help protect people from
malpractice and there is nothing in here
but I would like to see something if
it's possible that says if somebody is
going to be doing that they have to
State and get signed an understanding of
the patient of all of the risks whether
it's the surgery or whether it's the
hormones and other things that go with
it because I think I have met a number
of people who have gone through through
this and they did not they were not
informed of all of the potential risks
and I think that's very important and
then the other part um I wanted to talk
about the counseling and I am thrilled
to see that you are making it
specific that General counseling that is
not
compelling um is allowed because I have
spoken to counselors who felt that they
were not allowed to do any type of
counseling to um people with gender
dysphoria because of the law The Way It
Was
Written and a number of people if not
the majority of people who have gender
dysphoria have underlying issues be it
trauma or other things that it's very
important that they get proper
counseling for and I have spoken again
to various people who have transitioned
who did not get that counseling
because the counselors were afraid that
that would be disobeying the law the way
it's written now so I really appreciate
that you've opened that up and I hope
you will continue to support that so
that people can get the counseling that
they need to particularly exploring what
the underlying issues may be that they
have thank you thank
you questions from committee
members
I see no questions thank you thank you
very
much also signed up to speak is Lynn CER
Stanley from the National Association of
chapter good morning good morning again
you have three minutes thank you Mr
chairman and uh members of the committee
for hearing my testimony uh for the
record my name is Courier Stanley I'm a
licensed independent clinical social
worker and I'm the executive director of
the National Association of Social
Workers New Hampshire chapter
representing
850 members in the state of New
Hampshire uh I'm primarily going to
focus on the conversion therapy piece
but recognizing uh representative
kushman you said something about the
Trevor Project and people uh
who
uh transgender youth uh queer and
questioning youth having higher rates of
of depression it's not intrinsic within
the person who is
uh questioning their gender questioning
their sexuality to be depressed it is
uh more an outcropping of the way
Society treats people who are
questioning or uh or a transgender as
far as
the conversion therapy and that's a
misname there's nothing therapeutic
about this practice it is dangerous it
is harmful it is hurtful and years ago
when we got this band I I at first
wondered whether or not it was a
solution looking for a problem until I
heard the testimony of
hundreds of people who had been affected
and then also hearing from social
workers and psychologists and other
mental health professionals saying yes
I've had to treat people who had been
victims of this practice it is fine the
way it is written there were a few
people when they tried to overturn the
ban who were confused about what
about if it's not within your scope of
practice to do that work to work with
people who are uh questioning their
sexuality or or gender
identity then they need to refer them to
somebody who it is within their scope of
practice please leave the conversion
therapy ban alone it is
fine I'll I'll sum up my my testimony
and I'm happy to answer any questions
thank you questions from committee
Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the
question during your testimony you refer
to the external environment which is
basically Society versus the internal
one which is the
individual in saying that is there
any documentation or studies out there
in societies that are more accepting of
this practice and that impact it has on
depression I'm trying to get to is that
are the countries that are more
accepting therefore the individual has
less depression than we would find here
in the United States I I think we thank
you for the question and I'm happy to
find that research I think we can
extrapolate from what we're seeing right
now with some states that are you know
the don't say gay bills or Banning uh
gender affirming care outright the
numbers of suicide attempts
and the number of suicides has dumped
dramatically I can't say that this is a
causal relationship but I'm it sure
sounds like a very strong correlation
and I'm sure that the research will
start to meet it out in the next few
years other
questions representative Missour thank
you thank you for taking my question
could you please send us those stats
that you just said it sounded a little
bit like conjecture to me but if you
have exact St stats that say these
suicides are a result of this I would
love to see that yeah that's why I said
I I'm not saying that there's a so
it's it's a very strong correlation that
988 and the other suicide uh uh projects
are are reporting
on representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman um so I'm
wondering are you aware that the world
path these are the the
world practice
on assoc thank you you're familiar with
what w I'm sorry I'm not hearing what
your can you say again what it
is
wpath the world Prof Professional
Association of transitional Health okay
W path thank you um are you familiar
with that
organization not to speak okay on them
follow follow up um well they Define
conversion therapy as attempts to compel
a gender diverse child through words
actions or both to identify with or
behave in accordance with the gender
associated with the sex assigned at
Birth do you um agree that that's a
solid and appropriate definition for
conversion therapy that's their
definition of of conversion therapy what
I'm saying is
that conversion therapy is unethical for
any medical
or
uh
behavioral health
professional in New Hampshire all of the
other New England states New York New
Jersey and go out a little further it's
illegal it is a practice
that looks different depending on where
you are
and I don't think we need to go further
than what we already have in our ban on
conversion therapy follow up um okay but
you see where that's problematic where
we deal with law and we need solid
definitions how can we prohibit
something if we can't Define
it I think we did Define it in the
original
law okay any other questions from
committee
members seeing none okay thank you very
you also signed up to speak is Chris
glad good morning good morning thank you
chair thank you members of the committee
good few minutes my name is Chris urel
um I am with glad in Boston but I'm a
New Hampshire licensed
attorney I also have um extensive
experience litigating uh in the area of
access to health care for transgender
people including transgender
minors um I'm going to rush through a
few points because three minutes isn't
long to cover all this material um as
we've heard it is exceedingly rare that
anyone under the age of 18 ever has uh
has the kind of surgeries that are
prohibited in this uh Bill and in fact I
do have anecdotal um information about
those extremely rare cases if people
want to hear but I do want to point out
that only four between 2016 and 2020
only 405 surgeries of the type defined
in here were performed on people 18
years old and younger and that includes
18year olds the majority of those people
were 18y olds so we are talking about a
very very small number of uh surgeries
and the only place where I know anywhere
near here is Boston Children's Hospital
um where a surgery like that has ever
taken place and it is very rare even
there and I can talk more about that if
people have questions about it um I just
want to add though that in those
circumstances in which it's medically
indicated it is very very important for
those people to have access to the
healthare that they need it's not it's
not for any reason other than Medical
necess necessity that a 17-year-old
would ever go through a procedure like
that um and again I'm happy to talk more
if people have questions about it uh
when it comes to the uh prohibition on
insurance coverage I just want to point
out that it is pretty unusual for the
legislature to prohibit private
insurance uh private insurance companies
from providing benefits to people um of
any kind uh that's a very very rare to
see in any kind of legislation and it uh
kind of raises my eyebrows that that
that there's an effort you know
prohibiting certain practices is one
thing but then making a law that would
prohibit a private insurance company
from providing health benefits to an
individual is uh is is a step that goes
a little bit beyond um there's another
part of this bill that would um that
would that would uh insulate insurance
companies that didn't want to provide
coverage from um for gender transition
related Medical Care and I just want to
point out that that conflicts not only
with several New Hampshire statutes as
we've already heard it also uh conflicts
with the New Hampshire division of
Insurance's stated policy and it conf
conflicts with Section 1557 of the
Affordable Care Act which prohibits
discrimination on the basis of
transgender status in health benefits um
perhaps most alarming about this bill is
uh the um the the proposed amendments to
the ban on conversion therapy um as
we've heard Professionals in Med Medical
Care Mental Health Care Professionals do
not have trouble complying with with the
ban on conversion therapy it is not
confusing to them I would look with a
lot of Suspicion on any mental health
care provider who stated otherwise I do
want to point out that many states
besides New Hampshire including States
in New England and Beyond use exactly
the same language uh uh you know all you
have to do is a Google search practices
or treatments that seek to change an
individual sexual orientation or gender
identity it's very well understood you
can pleas start wrapping up yeah yeah
I'm concerned that a lot of the points
in the um conversion therapy amendments
reflect a fundamental misunderstanding
of gender identity no um with all due
respect to the drafters and I'm happy to
address any of the issues that I just
raised in more detail um so please feel
free to ask questions thank you
questions from committee members
representative
Weber thank you uh and thank you for
taking my question thank you for being
here today um I would indeed uh be very
interested in hearing more elaboration
on the issue of the conversion therapy
language yeah thank you so um I really
appreciate that question um so a
person's gender identity is not
something that can be changed it is
fixed from a very young age that's what
experts in the field have told us and so
what the bill suggests is that
counselors can transition or
detransition somebody according to their
wishes and the whole point of the banon
conversion therapy is to make it clear
that that is not possible what can
change and what does change is a
person's understanding of their gender
identity that changes over time that is
where a mental health provider can come
in and provide invaluable support to
someone who's seeking to understand
their gender identity um the word d
transition shows up in the amendment uh
which is just uh it's not a term of art
it's not a term that medical Mental
Health Care Professionals will use to
describe uh to describe a anything
gender transition is a process that
sometimes takes many turns and uh
because because understanding a person's
gender identity can be really difficult
for a number of reasons that I could you
know go into for hours talking about why
it's so hard for some young people
especially to understand their gender
identity so the fact that the word d
transition um shows up in here the fact
that we're talking about how um how a
how a provider can provide counseling
that changes a person's gender identity
this is not possible a person's gender
identity is fixed and a mental health
care provider can provide invaluable
support in helping a person understand
that um and that can involve helping a
person with social transition helping a
person work through issues related to
Medical transition and more but a
person's gender identity cannot be
changed and I just want to make sure
that's absolutely clear um but that's
not what the language of uh part C
suggests
followup it's actually not a follow-up
it's a whole new question if I may sure
uh the other thing you you uh touched on
but did not go into deeply um is uh the
issue of People who have actually had
the surgery at a younger age and the
necessity which I think you
characterized as a very deep necessity
medical necessity and I wish if you
could explain those um needs a little
bit more that would be helpful sure sure
I'm actually pretty familiar with a
specific court case which um because the
case is impounded because it involves a
minor I don't want to go into too much
detail describing it to un um to you
know uncover
uh you know private information about
people and their um and their intimate
details of their lives but but there is
a 17-year-old who um who who needed
surgery and I just want to say the
hospital where the surgery was performed
uh they would not perform it without a
court order so they asked uh the family
to file a lawsuit in court seeking a
judgment declaring that the hospital
must perform or has you know the legal
right to perform this surgery um and in
those in in this particular and doal
circumstance that I can share with you
there are some really important
characteristic things that I've heard in
other cases too uh first that the person
uh it was a transgender girl because as
as as repon has noted it's only
vaginoplasty that's performed on anyone
who's 17 years old um she was a
transgender girl who had been out you
know living as living as a girl from a
very very young age okay she was on her
way to college and experiencing severe
gender dysphoria due to her due to the
fact that her body did not conform to
her gender ident identity uh she was
about to go to college and she had one
opportunity one opportunity where she
could be in the care of her mother and
father in their home while recovering
from a very serious surgery before going
off and going to college where she was
going to then be uh you know in front of
her peers and in front of everybody else
without the protection and so she wanted
to be she needed to be uh secure in who
she was and in her body before she went
to college it's a very rare circumstance
that somebody is in this uh this
situation of need but um if you if you
knew the girl if you knew the
circumstances you would understand
completely why it was medical necess
medically necessary in that specific
case but again very rare that it's ever
medically
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you for taking the
question during the testimony what I
heard I think I heard was between the
years of 2016 and
2020 there were 4 such surgeries
45 and you talked about that was
including 18 and 17 what would be
interesting do we have any data about
how many of those were 17 and in the
state of New
Hampshire I can tell you that uh I wish
that there were the data splitting out
how many were 18 and 17 what I believe
is that the study that I was where I got
this information which I can provide to
the committee later um I believe what I
what I Intuit it is that they needed a
you know a number of sample size that
was large enough to perform any kind of
analysis so they needed to include 18y
olds they couldn't just look at 17y olds
right so I don't have that breakdown
unfortunately and I and I wish I knew
who did right um but uh how many people
from who are residents of the State of
New Hampshire and had that surgery in
New Hampshire I think the answer is zero
and then I think if you were to ask how
many people who are residents of the
State of New Hampshire um and had the
surgery elsewhere it is um probably
zero so the ones that don't qualify for
zero would they done again back to it
sounds like there's one Hospital in the
New England here in Boston Children's
Hospital is it their policy that in
order for them to perform the surgery
they require a court order um in that
one particular case they did and um and
I actually don't know if that happened
to be the first time that that ever
happened or not for that hospital but um
presuming it was it was in 2019 you know
thank you representative uh Missour and
then representative Weber yes thank you
for taking my question um are you
familiar have you read the W path
standard of care and are you familiar
with W path I'm very familiar with W
path I've read I haven't read every
everything and all the standards of care
they're pretty expansive so yeah okay
thank you I have another follow up um so
so is a d transitioner someone who
detransitioned um are they Contin do
they continue to experience gender
disphoria uh I would tend to use the
term someone who desists from uh and
then I would say either desists from
social transition or desists from um um
from from you know taking hormones or or
or something along those lines I
wouldn't use the term detransition if I
were talking professionally because I
don't think it's a professional term but
yeah they call themselves that but okay
well I mean I think you'll find some
people who do and some people who say I
desisted from treatment and uh or I
desisted from social transition right so
one quick yep would the surgery then be
considered necessary or successful in
those situations um can you please
clarify the question so if a if a person
who has transitioned MH you know has
gotten surgery MH and then decides to
detransition was that surgery considered
as a success I mean I think the question
is does that individual regret the
surgery right and um yeah there are rare
instances in which people have uh gender
gender uh gender transition related
surgeries and regret them and that's
really unfortunate and in fact um you
know medical standards of care must be
established in such a way to minimize uh
the level of regret I will uh note that
compared to other surgical interventions
um regret rates for gender transition
surgeries are lower um and and um and of
course uh as everyone should everyone
should have the right to exercise um um
you know uh exercise their rights
against any medical professional who
does not comply with the standards of
care when providing treatment and that's
why we have really robust uh medical
malpractice uh standards and laws in New
Hampshire and everywhere in the
country representative
Weber thank you my my question was
actually just a followup with respect to
the 405 surgery between 2016 and 2020
I'm not sure I wrote down what the
geographical area those were in that was
the United States I apologize if I
didn't that was the whole United the
whole United States the whole United
States for for those for those years
those five
years and a followup just a quick
followup would you believe that I very
much regret having parted with my uula
to treat sleep app
Nia I would believe it thank
you would you further believe that I was
informed that it might not help and I
chose to do it anyway thank
you I would believe that yes other
questions uh representative
Canon we we we've talked a bit about
detransitioning do you are you aware of
um any numbers associate with people
that have dis have detransitioned who
have transitioned back oh I do know that
I mean I know anecdotally of situations
in which that happen sometimes someone
will transition to living socially as
another gender and I just want to point
out while we're talking about
detransition or desisting um that there
is um a number of reasons that a person
might detransition and might include
regret it might include um it might
include you know uh a person coming to
terms with understanding that their
gender dysphoria wasn't telling them
what they thought it was telling them
and it might involve somebody who said
the social pressures that come along
with living as a different gender are
actually much much greater than I was
prepared for either because uh my
personal transition story didn't allow
me to uh to assimilate as well as I
thought I could or because I just
experienced so much discrimination you
know I I hear a number of stories from
all you know all aspects including
regret but but I just want to point out
that it's a really wide range and yes
sometimes people um on their journey of
you know understanding their gender
identity might transition and then might
detransition or trans you know
transition back and then might
transition back again and then sometimes
people will discover that they have a
non-binary gender identity but they
weren't necessarily open to that
possibility at an earlier age there's so
many different you know paths that a
person might take and I think it's
really important to ensure that
everybody has the right and ability and
all the tools that they need to help
find out how to live as comfortably as
they can in their gender
identity other questions representative
ma thank you again um yeah so I when
someone
wants to de detransition do you know
what the billing codes for that standard
of care would be again uh the the
medical treatment wouldn't be considered
D transition it would be considered
transition related care it would be
considered gender transition related
care for somebody to either desist
taking hormones or for somebody to have
other surgical treatments or anything
else so is is that a fact or opinion
because I have heard the opposite that
there are billing codes for
transitioning and so would you agree
that in in another state next door to us
there would not be billing codes for
those who choose to transition D
transition well I are you talking about
surg surgical treatment specifically all
of it all of it okay
so billing codes associated with a
specific hor I mean okay I'm not an
insurance expert but I think that we're
talking about some really really
complicated stuff here when you know a
person who is prescribed hormone therapy
the billing code I think is associated
with the medication not with a diagnosis
or what it's intended to treat right and
I think that's true generally for um
surgical treatments as well um but there
there are certainly going to be um
instances in which a surgical treatment
will be Associated only with gender
transition so I I just think that it's
like a really complicated question
that's beyond beyond the scope of this
amendment for sure representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here and taking my question um
I think the Crux of the issue that
representative Missour was trying to get
to is that that it's difficult to track
um a lot of times people who no longer
want to continue on their path to
transition to um the different gender
that they were born um end up ghosting
the clinic that they used to go to and
just get off the hormones on their own
oftentimes there's no follow-up care and
there's no post care um
surveillance and so we have a couple of
studies um you know we've got like 11
studies today that show that if children
aren't affirmed and there's watchful
waiting that um the vast majority the
gender dysphoria resolves and then we
have other studies um the most recent
and large one published in 2021 followed
139 boys from 7 to 21 years old and
showed that as adults um 87% grew
outgrew their gender dysphoria so we
don't have the stats on regret but we do
have the stats on um you know change uh
out growing the dysphoria to an extent
but you see the problem with the billing
codes do you you see how that could lend
to it seeming like there's a lot less
detransitioning than is uh
pervy um may I suggest that if this
committee and this legislature are
concerned with the availability of
competent care for people who wish to
desist from gender transition that uh
that legislation um be enacted to the
healthare options available to those
individuals I think that would be a
fantastic use of this legislature's
resources in
time follow up well wouldn't it be um
effective to
also pass this legislation and then
prevent those horrible regret cases from
occurring in the first place if you're
suggesting that it was better to prevent
people from getting healthare that they
need because there might be a small
percentage of the people who get it who
end up regretting the healthare that
they need then I would disagree with
you let's move on um any other questions
for this U
person seeing no other questions thank
you thank you so much
oh sorry representative Shapero my pen
your badge is under he dropped his badge
under the desk okay thank you I can see
it that's why they make them orange
they're easy to find
yeah
I also signed up to speak is Beth scare
themselves good morning hi Beth scare
from NASA and again you have three
minutes thank you um I'm here to ask you
to vote um a to pass on this amendment
to HB
619 I have met and heard the stories
from many D transitioners the M vast
majority who are girls who have deep
regret for the rible damage to their
bodies girls who are confused about
their gender and many who also have
comorbid serious mental health health
problems such as autism
ADHD and PTs are being led down the path
of medical transitions starting with pu
puberty blockers followed by cross- seex
hormones and finally having their
healthy body parts
removed with girls this means most often
means radical double mastectomies
leaving large painful scars and taking
away the sexual function of the breast
and the ability to breastfeed their
babies the pain from the scars and from
Phantom breast syndrome
can be lifelong these girls don't have a
grasp on what they are giving up and
what physical problems they are taking
on there's no reason to rush these
procedures when these girls have so much
at stake and can make a decision for
surgery later in life when they have the
life experience and the Brain
development to make these
decisions this amendment would not only
protect children from lifelong regret it
would also protect medical providers who
risk being the target of
lawsuits numerous lawsuits have been
brought by D transitioners against their
medical providers for medically
transitioning them when they were
underage the most famous of these D
transitioners is Khloe Cole who is suing
Kaiser Permanente in
California you may have heard of her
tragic story of having a double Mass
ectomy at 15 and beginning the process
of d transitioning at
18 she says my life My Teenage life has
been the culmination of excruciating
pain regret and most importantly
Injustice I have been emotionally and
physically damaged and stunted by
so-called medical professionals in my
most important developmental period I
was butchered by an institution that we
trust more than anything else in our
lives what is worse is that I'm not
alone in my pain I will see to the fact
that the Blood and Tears of D
transitioners like myself will not lay
waste it is impossible for me to recoup
what I have lost but I will ensure no
children will be harmed the hands of
these liars and
mutilators New Hampshire medical
professionals are at risk of these
lawsuits if they remove the healthy body
parts of gender confused children please
vote ought to pass on this amendment and
protect kids from irreversible damage to
their bodies and lifelong regret and New
Hampshire medical professionals from
lawsuits thank
you thank you questions from committee
members representative kushman thank you
Mr chairman thank you for being here uh
are you familiar with the lawsuit filed
by Isabella aella in uh Rhode Island
recently yeah can are you able to tell
us a little bit about that um from what
I read um she's not only suing the
clinician who um led her and supported
her in her gender uh transition
experience but also the American Academy
of Pediatrics for fraud for their
guidelines that were issued in
2018 um and the studies that um that are
cited as supporting those guidelines as
being uh fraudulent and not proving what
they say to proove Excuse excuse me
representative n do you have a point of
order I believe I do I thought we could
ask questions of a testimony not
introduce completely new testimony which
uh if representative kushman wanted to
present testimony maybe she should fill
out a card and get in line she was
talking about lawsuits so I wanted to
ask her seemed a little farfetched to me
but I
just I'm not
debating the I'm just the
appropriateness of my inter was she was
just trying to find out if the witness
was aware of this and and what if she
might have additional information is
that correct representative frishman yes
um the one of one of the practitioners
that is being sued is Jason Rafferty who
wrote those guidelines for the AAP and
um soon after those were published um
James caner wrote uh a huge takeown of
it um pointing out how the the supposed
data was
fraudulent um there was no you know
there was no scientific evidence what
they were saying and now he he was one
of the doctors treating Isabella and so
he's getting sued the ap's getting sued
and I I don't see how the gender medical
complex can can go forward with this the
way they're treating kids fraudulently
representative
Shapero thank you Mr chair um I may have
this wrong but I believe in the
beginning of your testimony you talked
about having met a lot of people who
have are detransitioning and I'm
wondering in what context either
professionally or are these how have you
met these people um well Khloe Cole well
first of all um Katie Anderson lives
well she doesn't live in New Hampshire
but she works and goes to church here in
New Hampshire and she's been doing a lot
of speaking around the state we we saw
her last night in
gtown and then Khloe Cole was here um in
April and um pra
Mosley um visited shortly after that um
and I've and of course I've been reading
testimony so then it would be accurate
to say that these are people who have
been speaking publicly and you've heard
and followed rather than um perhaps
working as a social worker who has a lot
of people coming to see you who've had
this problem
or being a parent and having a lot of
your kids friends who are having this
problem that that you when you say
you've met a lot of people these are
people who are
um who are speaking out and um
nationally well um I've also spend I
also do a lot of reading of the drr
subreddit where people go on there
privately they don't want to reveal
their identity and they're ter terribly
afraid to reveal their identities and
they talk about the horrible regret and
a lot of them H you know a lot of these
procedures happening when they're
children and they just they they say
over and over again didn't know I didn't
know of course they didn't know their
kids thank you very much other questions
thanks also signed up to speak is Ava
Society
had to check to see if it's still
morning so good morning thank you for
having me and allowing me to
testify um dear chairman McDonald and
members of the health health human
services and RW Affairs committee my
name is Ava Hawks and I'm the director
of advocacy for the New Hampshire
Medical Society the New Hampshire
Medical Society strongly opposes House
Bill 619 as well as the replace all
non-main Amendment 2359 being proposed
today the New Hampshire Medical
society's mission is to advocate for the
well being of our patients for our
profession and for the betterment of
Public Health the Physicians of the
Granite State our members honor this
Mission every day by centering patient
care around Health Equity and
inclusivity combating discriminatory
policies and legislative initiatives
that make our state unsafe to
marginalized groups such as lgbtq plus
youth our state's Physicians who provide
gender affirming care GAC know that such
healthc care is well researched
medically necessary and safe these
providers are also aware of the data
surrounding the harmful and more
devastating life-threatening outcomes
for our gender diverse youth when
policies such as what is set forth in
Amendment
2359 an outright prohibition of GAC in
the form of genital gender reassignment
surgery for minors dangerously
conflating GAC with conversion therapy
and an encouraging insurers to restrict
coverage for GAC surgeries are
implemented in December of 2022 the
Trevor Project released a detailed
analysis of nearly 34,000 LGBT youth
ages 13 to 24 across the 50 states the
survey reported that
39% of lgbtq Youth in New Hampshire had
seriously considered suicide in the past
year while about 10% had attempted
suicide furthermore the Physicians of
the Live Free or Die State also oppose
government overreach into provider
patient relationships Amendment 2359 and
the underlying Bill seeks to disrupt and
dissuade providers from providing evid
evidence-based Health Care to gender
diverse youth with parental SLG Guardian
consultation free from discri
discrimination and the further
marginalization of such vulnerable
populations for these reasons New
Hampshire Medical Society strongly
encourages the health health human
services and elderly Affairs committee
to vote down Amendment 2359 and vote
House Bill 619 and expedient to
legislate thank you for your time and
consideration of my testimony and I'm
happy to take any questions back to the
experts that are the
Physicians thank you any questions from
committee
thank you Mr chairman um I'm
specifically wondering um can you speak
to the long-term data on the perianal
pull through vaginal
plasties I thank you for the question
representative I am flattered that you
thought I could answer that question but
I I know a number of Physicians who have
submitted written testimony that our
members who provide this care in New
Hampshire then I'm sure I'm happy to
take that question back to them and get
a clear answer for you I would hate to
and accurately represent that can I add
two questions to that them to get to us
um are are these you may want to give
her a chance to BU down the first one
yeah um could you repeat the first one
so specifically um what's the long-term
data look like on the perianal pull
through vaginal plasties those are the
ones that are required to take um col
colonic tissue essentially um be in
cases where say there are a couple of
reasons why
um but puberty blockers would be one
there's not enough penile tissue um to
use okay and then the other is
um is uh is that safe and effective
data and then just uh the last one would
be how many of these surgeries are
performed on children in New Hampshire
each
year any genital gender reassignment
surgeries not specifically the paranal
pull through but we should have that
delineated as well as phow
plasties okay thank you you're welcome
thank you other questions from committee
members representative Missour yes thank
you um yeah so the statement in here
says similar to what representative
kushman just said but just to clarify so
our state's Physicians who provide
gender affirming care care does that
include gender reassignment surgery
that's a great question so I know um you
all should have re received written
testimony uh via the virtual signin from
Dr Francis Lim Liberty who works with
Dartmouth and I believe um Courtney
Tanner who represents Dartmouth spoke on
the testimony that you folks were
received and I believe that question is
covered in her testimony unfortunately
there were no providers represented here
today so we were not able to get that
information they will be sending it
along but we still haven't heard that
today okay I'm happy to bring that bring
that question back to the surface thank
you you're welcome representative Weber
but just to be clear my understanding is
that you're saying that that testimony
has already been uploaded to our general
court website correct thank
you representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair could you
repeat the uh position that did the
upload on that testimony um so I believe
it's going to be the I think it was a
letter with multiple signes but Dr
Francis Lim Liberty of Dartmouth thank
you yeah other
questions seeing no other question thank
you very much thank
you oh I'm sorry representative Palmer
it's not really a question it's just
that we had heard earlier that there
have been zero surgeries in in juveniles
in New Hampshire and I did check with um
contact at Dartmouth yesterday and they
don't perform any under 18 18 bottom
surgeries and actually they don't do any
transgender surgeries under the age of
18 that doesn't cover all of New
Hampshire but that's Dartmouth thank
thanks also signed up to speak this
morning is Paula minahan from the new
Association
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee get three minutes yeah um my
name is Paula minihan Senior vice
president state government relations for
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals um both
community and Specialty hospitals the
hospital Association is opposed to House
Bill 619 as introduced as well as the
non-gain amendment number um 2023 2359 H
which would amend RSA 332 to prohibit
gender surgery on Miners and prohibit
conversion therapy on miners the New
Hampshire Hospital Association supports
policies which Advance Health Equity and
inclusion for all individuals House Bill
619s non gerain amendment is contrary to
the principles of Health Equity and
inclusion and would be discriminatory
towards an often marginalized group in
our society in addition the non-gain
amendment is an overreach by effectively
attempting to legislate the practice of
medicine this is a precedent that should
be avoided furthermore prohibiting all
public and private insurers from being
required to provide coverage for gender
affirming Health Care further
discriminates against this often
marginalized segment of our society we
also believe this am Amendment would
conflict as um Miss Reed from the ACLU
identified um it conflicts with current
health insurance non-discriminatory
statutes as well as other
non-discriminatory state statutes we
strongly urge you to find this non-gain
amendment and the underlying bill as an
expedient to legislate and thank you for
the opportunity to provide these
comments thank
you questions from committee members
representative
Merchant thank you m chair and thank you
Miss in a hand foring the question in
regards to the insurance earlier I asked
about the issue of Rissa in whether the
state law has any impact on the benefits
that one can provide under the Risa
plans I know you're not an insurance per
se but you sort of alluded to it as far
as in your testimony would there be
somebody in the hospital Association or
somewhere we could get that kind of
information back to us um thank you
representative for the um question while
I um don't represent insurers I did work
for one for a number of years um orisa
as you indicated is um does not fall
under State Statute so that would there
there's no ability those statutes um
that are cited in the amendment um would
not cover Arisa plans just like they
won't cover Medicare or they won't cover
um um Medicare Advantage
either other questions from committee
members seeing none thank you very much
thank
you
also signed up to speak is Kate West
herself okay um okay all
right I I'll put it I'll keep it down
I'll move it down in the pack
then also signed up to speak is Kim
herself
minutes there we go before I get to my
prepared testimony I just want to um
take issue with the level of
condescension um earlier um that parents
will be unable to grasp the nuances of
this type of care and by implication
that licensed medical providers would
also require input from this body um as
the only I'm going to have to you have
three minutes to so excuse me you have
three minutes for your testimony thanks
for thanks for making me pause um
because this body is the only one
capable of grasping this topic I'm a PhD
chemist and I'm also an attorney facts
matter to me and polics have no place
politics have no place in the provision
of medical
care as a legislator in the in New
Hampshire you swore to faithfully and
impartially discharge and perform all
your duties incumbent on you as a state
representative impartiality requires at
at least a modum of research on the
relevant subject prior to proposing any
law to a Bridges citizen's right over
1.3 million doctors recognize the
medical necessity of transition related
care for improving the physical and
mental health of transgender people
especially young people as a parent of a
transgender son it's bills like this
that encourage the daily systematic
attacks on his safety and on his mere
existence your actions have very real
consequences and you Purp are inflicting
harm on children of New Hampshire the
group that you claim to care so much
about HB 619 is born out of willful
ignorance of the facts and is a blatant
attempt yes point of order sorry we
don't we don't apply motive here you
said that we're deliberately inflicting
can you at least give me the um the
courtesy of letting me speak we've
listened to we will ma'am we just want
to clarify nobody is trying to harm
anybody we may disagree on issue well I
would I would take issue with that um
you know making root requiring people to
um prove their worthiness for medical
care um we don't want to debate ma'am
just just finish your testimony
please while my child has not required
these treatments there's no need to ban
it for those who do despite M multiple
Doctorate Degrees my biggest
accomplishment to date has been keeping
my son
alive um I just think the fact that you
sit here and you think you know what's
best for people you've never met is
disgraceful um and your input is
unwanted uninformed and dangerous
this is inexpedient to legislate thank
you also signed up to speak is Michelle
herself hopefully I pronounced the name
right I'm I'm not sure I did but
Michelle siloy yes okay great you have
three minutes thank you chair and
members of the committee for listening
to our testimonies today today my name
is Michelle syoy and I live in Temple
New Hampshire I'm a mother of six and
also a physical therapist the last three
years of my full-time job has been being
a mom to my four youngest at first
staying home was due to the pandemic now
it's for a different reason my
16-year-old child has been struggling
with many physical and mental health
issues over the past three years this
past year they transitioned to
homeschooling due to their severe
migraines unfortunately we didn't
realize at the time just how severe our
child's Depression was or that they were
also experiencing gender dysphoria in
March for the first time in my presence
they expressed they were experiencing
near constant Suicidal Thoughts while at
a physician visit immediately I sought
counseling for them after beginning
therapy they were slowly able to talk
more openly to us about things in
September they came to me and asked if
they were too old to start hormone
therapy after that conversation a Hu
huge weight lifted from our child's mind
we now have seen an endocrinologist and
are beginning the process of starting
hormone replac replacement therapy to
allow our child to have a more feminine
body they get at home in my queer child
has started their own journey and I'm
here to support them however I can
witnessing the self-isolation and severe
depression my child has endured has been
horrific and painful as their mother a
heartache I hope few parents have to
cope with we are incredibly fortunate to
continue to have our child here with us
today in their attempted after their
attempted suicide recently I sat in a
doctor's office while at their side as
they reveal details of that attempt
there attempt was before they came to me
about HRT before they were able to
express how lost they were feeling in
their own body now there is finally
light creeping through the darkness they
have been living in as their mom I am
able to feel hope again for their future
I am grateful every day that their
beautiful face is still here for me to
touch I know for certain that they would
not be if it wasn't for the gender
affirming care that they will soon
receive if you were to ask my teenager
today if they hope to have gender
affirming surgery they will say I don't
know if they come to me next year and
they say they need surgery I will
support them until they are able to find
the care they require for their survival
it is not the place of the legislature
to determine when a referral is
medically necessary for essential health
care and block insurance coverage for
that care gender affirming care is
always medically necessary and is life-
saving at every age as a mother and a
medical professional I know how to
advocate for my children I ask questions
I listen and I trust I trust in both the
practitioners providing care for my
family and I trust in my children's word
if my child is unable to live in a body
that is not the one that they were
biologically given at 16 years old I
cannot comprehend how that suddenly
becomes a legal right at 18 most
importantly I cannot fathom how it is
expected that their mental health would
support them to live through such
struggle to reach 18 many transgender
kids die by Suicide due to gender
dysphoria they experience and the
extreme mental anguish they struggle
through every day as a mother I support
the Essential Medical Care that can be
life-saving for teens like mine
please vote itl for HB
619 thank you you taking questions or if
anyone has any questions representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair I I just want
to thank you for sharing What's um
obviously a very personal and um at
times very painful experience and I hope
that it's more hopeful now it seems like
it is thank you thank you very much
other
questions
you also signed up to speak is Elijah
themselves good morning and again you
have three minutes thank you um I'm
actually reading his testimony for him
him his brother got uh deployed to Iraq
and okay are you are you Kate mccardy
yes okay all right okay right thank you
uh so again these are Elijah's words uh
let me be very clear there is absolutely
nothing wrong or unnatural about being
transgender as a transgender man myself
I grappled with the feelings of
internalized transphobia and shame for
most of my life now that I have been
able to access gender affirming care I
have been able to live a much happier
healthier life there are a lot of
misconcep ctions and misinformation
surrounding gender affirming care
especially when it comes to care for
minors minors rarely receive any surgery
and those receiving surgery are 16 or 17
not young children let me frame it this
way the age of consent in the state of
New Hampshire is 16 years of age a
16-year-old can legally get pregnant and
bear a child why do we trust the
cisgender heterosexual teenager to go
through pregnancy a permanent medical
decision and raise a child but not the
transgender teenager who feels so
dysphoric and uncomfortable in their own
skin that they need to undergo the
process to receive gender affirming care
now let me also be very clear that no
teenager in New Hampshire is able to
readily get gender affirming genital
surgeries there is therapy reference
letters and long wait times involved
despite all of this trans people still
go through the process to receive care
why because gender affirming care is
life-saving and necessary I survived
four suicide attempts before I turned 18
years old this committee has been told
time and time again the statistics on Su
side and trans youth HB 619 is
unnecessary and flies in the face of all
the major medical organizations that
have already stated that gender
affirming care is medically necessary
the American College of Physicians among
other leading medical organizations has
condemned efforts to criminalize gender
affirming care and other evidence-based
care as interference with the physician
patient relationship receiving gender
affirming care is the only
evidence-based approach to address
gender dysphoria and transgender
teenagers parental rights are of also
often mentioned in the discourse around
gender affirming care I have a quote
from a parent who I know is supportive
of their trans child bans on gender
affirming care infringe on my right to
take care of my child in the way that
makes sense to me and is supported by
scientific evidence why are my rights as
a supportive parent given less weight
than those who wish to not support their
trans kid decisions on General affirming
care should be left to the patient their
doctor and their parents I do not know
every single transgender minor in the
state of New Hampshire so I cannot speak
on whether the fact
they should or should not receive gender
affirming care this committee does not
know every single terance gender minor
in the state of New Hampshire so
important medical decisions like
receiving gender affirming care should
be left to those who understand the
individual situation the most the
patient doctor and their parents I ask
this committee to vote in expedient to
legislate all forms on House Bill 619
thank you thank you um you're speaking
for someone else are you prepared to
take any questions are you just
ttim it depends on the question I can't
speak for him but sure are there any
question representative
Weber thank you and I think I will
unravel that particular question um did
I understand you to say at the beginning
of before you read the testimony that
Elijah is currently deployed overseas no
his brother just got called up his
brother I see so he's supporting his
brother yes okay thank you very much and
um we wish his brother well and thank
him for his service thank
you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you very
you also signed up to speak is Lind
minutes my name is Lind Jake house I use
they them pronouns I live in Dover I'm a
non-binary
transperson um and I am strongly opposed
to the current bill and the amendment um
and urge committee members to vote itl
on either um
as someone who has been active with um
supporting the transgender community in
New Hampshire since
2017 um I just want to state that
there's no form of HB 619 that is
acceptable gender affirming healthc care
is medically necessary health care and
all of it from puberty blockers to
hormones to surgeries is deemed safe by
every major medical
organization um I am someone who hopes
to be a parent in the next couple of
years and if my a child were to be um a
trans daughter and she were to tell me
that she needed puberty blockers
hormones even surgery at um under the
age of 18 which would only be likely to
happen at 17 I would do absolutely
everything in my power to support her um
including seeking a referral out of
state if we were not able to find and
Care in New Hampshire um and I would be
a extremely upset if um insurance was
not able to cover it I think it's
unprecedented to try to block insurance
from covering these procedures um in
2018 I attended the hearings um that
ultimately removed the exclusion on
Medicaid covering gender affirming and
Care um and the last step of that
committee or Le last step of that
process was the joint legislative
committee on administrative rules I was
really deeming that um the exclusion
needed to be removed to bring new
Hampshire into compliance with the
Affordable Care Act um and to not be
opened up for any lawsuits so I'm not a
lawyer but my understanding is that um
or stopping um reversing that decision
for Medicaid would open up New Hampshire
to lawsuits and I have never seen any
kind of legislation that would seek to
block uh private insurance from covering
any kind of care um again this as care
only happens in a very small number of
transgender girls who have um started
the transition process early um I only
know of one anecdotal evidence of one
trans girl getting in the surgery out of
state um not sure if it's the same
person that attorney Chris ell referred
to or not um but that's the only
anecdotal evidence that I know of of one
person getting that right before or
college um and this these decisions are
always always made between a doctor
parents and um the minor involved after
much discussion um and other steps
including in hormones prior to that um
and it's not up for this body to ban any
sort of of medical care you all are not
um or medical professionals or experts
on on this type of care we should trust
doctors to do this as Case by case where
it is necessary to relieve a dysphoria
um and your time is up sure I'm happy to
take any questions okay thank you any
questions from committee
much also signed up to speak is El Elena
mcdna representing
herself
good morning good morning or good
afternoon oh I'm sorry got to keep up
with the times literally good afternoon
Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
my name is Elanor mcdna I live in exiter
and I'm opposed to HB 619 and as amended
New Hampshire is a state that values
personal freedom for its citizens and
this legislation is a significant blow
to the medical freedoms that we hold
dear this discriminatory bill is
government overreach at its worst and
would set a terrifying precedent that
the government knows better than parents
on how to raise their kids putting the
state in between parents teens and their
doctors comparisons on gender affirming
care with use of tanning booths and
heroin are not appropriate examples as
those are not medical procedures that
are approved by the major professional
medical organizations in our country
when legislating against personal
medical rights any infringement is not
only dangerous it's a slippery slope it
is not the role of government to decide
if care which is widely acknowledged as
the best treatment for gender dysphoria
is medically
necessary as a transwoman I know from my
own personal experience that gender
affirming care is essential lifesaving
Healthcare among trans Youth desistance
and d-transition rates are incredibly
low the most recent study this year in
the prestigious Journal Pediatrics
showed that 97.5% of trans youth
continue to identify as Trans on a
5-year followup the sample size was also
larger than all previous sample sizes of
this population 317 trans youth trans
kids are insistent persistent and
consistent about who they are and the
Nationwide trend of legislating against
their existence is not only disturbing
it is having a negative impact on their
mental health it's time for these
performative attacks on them and state
legislatur to stop it's also time to
stop using the time of this important
body on unnecessary regulations and in
instead focus on the real issues that
Granite Staters care about like access
to housing education quality jobs and
our environment New Hampshire should
continue to be a place where all
families feel free to raise their
children without fear please vote itl on
this bill and this amendment thank you
thank
questions seeing none thank you thank
chairman also assign but to speak is
Bill
Bloom good morning good afternoon good
afternoon everyone long time no see hope
everyone's been well um my name is Bill
Blum I'm from Portsmouth New Hampshire I
am also non-binary and I use the them
pronouns um here to highlight a couple
of things I won't repeat what's been
said because I I think the points been
made um I did not write testimony today
I've come from lived experience and one
thing that stood out to me in the
beginning was the last five words of the
Pledge of Allegiance that we all looked
at that flag over there and recited them
if you do not remember what they are
it's liberty and justice for all this
proposed legislation and Amendment Mar
uh is
a
exclusive practice it is not inclusive
to all people it is excluding an already
marginalized Community I am a part of I
am visible and present for the invisible
our community in of itself is protective
it's secretive and that's because people
are afraid to either share their story
publicly or they're afraid to live
authentically because
of something the home might not be safe
for the
families or there's other reasons that I
I can keep going on about what I won't
um what I will
say is the medical professionals have
already testified I come from uh a place
where data dries decisions I'm not an
expert
in uh being a doctor and I am an well
not an expert I am I do have lived
experiences being a transgendered
non-binary individual so I can speak to
that um however I se I feel that none of
you have sat in a doctor's office as a
physician or someone who's providing
care to someone who actually needs
gender affirming care so I find it
difficult to hear about how personal
opinions will get in the way of medical
decisions um I see that this proposed
legislation will will harm and continue
to harm our community uh when the
similar legislation came up earlier this
year the day that it was shut down uh a
teen actually did commit suicide within
our community jumped off the bridge 293
um so this is real we are here we are
seen uh there was talk earlier about 405
surgeries were performed Over The Last 5
Years easy math let's call it 100 a year
none of them were new New Hampshire so
we're here to talk about New Hampshire
the other thing we're going to talk
about is the D transitioners I've lived
in this community for a long time
secretively and now publicly I've never
met one from New Hampshire so if they
would like
to send me a message I'd love to chat
with them my information's
public um and again I will close well I
will close Now with uh it's Halloween
people it's my favorite holiday please
be kind to the people people show up to
your door including the boy in the dress
or the girl in the Superman costume we
are all people and we will all be seen
today as well as tomorrow thank you
you're welcome any
welcome also signed up to speak is Nancy
Beerman
again you you indicate you'd like three
to five minutes please keep it to three
oh yes thank
you hi Nancy Beerman um good afternoon
uh we all started in the
morning um I am speaking um telling
going to tell you a story about a
32-year-old woman who in 1969 had
experienced five miscarriages and went
to her doctor and said I would like to
have a child um this woman was my
mother-in-law and she was given a drug
called Dees which is a synthetic
artificial synthetic
non-steroidal estrogen and endrin
disruptor this drug was uh sold to
patients and doctors to prevent
spontaneous abortions despite the lack
of proven efficacy they had no proof
this would
work her doctor said let's give this one
shot um she took uh the drug and uh she
did have a successful pregnancy but we
now know from history that that those
shots and that drug did nothing to make
that pregnancy happen what it did do is
create um
multi-generational problems for any
person born after having their mother
take that drug we have Dees children who
are born with uh
abnormalities
cancer they have a higher risk of cancer
than anyone else and we are now seeing
that the
grandchildren are having uh effects from
this
drug my mother-in-law uh thankfully in
some aspects um does not know that the
drug she took will be affecting her two
grandchildren she passed away at the age
of
59 she was diagnosed at 53 with a very
rare type of uterine
cancer um and at that point there was
nobody made the connection that it was
from this drug that she took to have a
pregnancy state I'm talking about this
drug um because it did finally get
banned in 1970 one year after she took
it it took until 1980 for it to get
banned in
Europe um and it still even after that
was still being given not to humans but
to animals and so it ended up into the
food supply finally in the year
2000 the year that her first grandchild
was born it was finally designated as a
carcinogen as far as her grandchildren
right now we do know uh from studies
that there are neurodevelopmental issues
which both my children suffer
from I will not ever share with my
children that they are suffering this
because of a choice their grandmother
made an uninformed de your time is up if
you could wrap up
please um I just want to say that every
service industry and that's what the
medical society is a service industry
needs to be regulated and they don't
know all the answers and but we do have
proof from Europe that the drugs and the
surgeries don't work and I suggest that
we pass this Bill thank you thank you
questions from committee members
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for um sharing
that story with us um
when you say that they don't work are
you seeing the same studies that are
showing that um that mental health and
suicide ideation is higher after
transition care or gender affirming care
starts hormones puberty blockers or is
it something
else I'm saying that giving the hormones
and the and the blockers too they are
causing more physical
damage um they have studies uh done
where the uh
bones um are breaking um of young
children that were given blockers or any
hormone um we're in my opinion we're
playing with Mother Nature and when we
start introducing
artificial uh things into the body there
are consequences and maybe unintended
consequences but there are consequences
to changing what nature and God has
already provided for us other
questions say no other questions thank
Smith good
afternoon thank you for taking my
testimony um I am a transgender woman
and I am also a retired medical
physician um I also while I can't
represent P flag New Hampshire I've been
very active with P flag New Hampshire
and know multiple not also through
personal connections multiple parents of
transgender girls and I think that's the
Germain thing in this first section I'm
not going to speak to the second section
I think the um Mental Health Providers
have spoken quite well to it but the
fact that there is currently
no provider in New Hampshire
providing um the gender affirming
surgery Galo surgery because I point out
that this amendment I've already spoken
against the underlying Bill last
spring um that
the testimony about uh breast reduction
surgery um or removal is non- gerine to
this non- gerine amendment because this
is about Gult surgery and I want to just
Echo what has already been said about
the emotional impact if you
interfere because you've selected 18
solely because that's after 18 the legal
age at which this person can now make
their own decisions and the fact is I
know multiple parents whose children
have in this more modern era been able
to talk to their parents early on about
their gender
dysphoria and get the appropriate care
and I have yet to hear as was indicated
before of any one of those people
regretting with parental support and
other support transitioning
and if you say to a 16 or 17year
old great you're going to graduate and
you're going to get to go out and do
this that and the other and they have no
chance of feeling
comfortable in their own body as an
adult because they didn't get a chance
to have that surgery and you're
threatening to criminalize even
referring them across state lines for
this then you really are having a huge
impact on that family and I would beg
you not to go down that path I mean I
also would say as a medical provider you
have no
business doing this kind of thing about
something you really don't
understand and you're not criminalizing
other
surgeries being provided because oh my
gosh we haven't had adequate follow-up
studies well that has happened on on
quite a few things and I think as
medical providers we've gotten a lot
better since the dees story and by the
way that Dees story from then those
providers were going against their
own Medical Professional societies that
had already said well before that don't
give
Dees your time is up if you could so and
you know I'm happy to answer any
Weber thank you um thank you for taking
my question and welcome back thank you
um I'm interested in this exploration
from a medical provider's
perspective of having to weigh the
risks of a bad outcome and and virtually
every medical procedure that I've ever
undergone I have been told that there
were risks of a bad outcome and I chose
whether to have the procedure or not
based on
that
um am I
not could you speak generally to the
risks on the one side of a bad outcome
of a procedure or a treatment as applied
to uh minors with gender dysphoria
versus the risk of leaving them without
the
treatment that is needed yeah I think
that's unfortunately so
individual that it requires good Studies
by non-biased individuals and I think a
lot of things that have been cited about
worse outcomes after gender treatment
are really kind of trying to find people
who are unhappy still and there's lots
of reasons to still be unhappy it can be
very hard to make this work believe me I
didn't try to make it publicly work
until I'd retired and I had already been
on cross- sex hormones for a couple of
decades um it's just this is tough stuff
and by the way cross- seex hormones are
not toxic that's a
mischaracterization they are not
toxic
so other
questions any other
West good afternoon good afternoon thank
you for the opportunity to speak my name
is Kate West I live right here in
conquer
I'm here to speak in opposition to HB
619 and this
amendment um every person has the right
to make medical decisions for themselves
and their children with the guidance of
their chosen Medical Professional no
person or group should have that right
threatened or revoked as Representatives
it is imperative that you trust the
people you represent to make decisions
about their own bodies and for their own
families as was stated there are always
risks and there are always rewards to
proposed medical treatment and it is up
to the patients and their medical
professionals to decide the path that is
best for each individual as was also
stated these situations are very nuanced
and there are so many variables that
that come uh with these situations for
each individual patient that you simp
simply as a governing body do not have
the time to sit in a room with each
individual case and make that caseby
casee decision with them that is best
left to their medical professionals and
themselves
um so each person is best equipped to
know what is healthy and necessary for
them and their family they're best
equipped when given the information to
make decisions based on their own health
and what they know is the best path
forward for that
I believe that this proposed amendment
and legislation is taking away the
rights of people to make their own
choices for
themselves uh so please recommend to the
full committee to vote itl on this bill
and Amendment thank you thank you any
you and the final person who who has
tangue Robert tangue
here apparently not uh I have no other
no one else signed up does anyone else
wish to testify on this U this
amendment seeing N I am going to close
this public hearing on um on this uh
amendment to House Bill
619 uh specifically Amendment um
23598 thank you all for being here and
adjourned